everybody I'm just waiting for the
elevator here with Chris Hardwick
welcome back thanks a real time it was
great
how do you feel about the show tonight
it was good it was Jake we're just doing
a digital thing for their for their
digital thing Jake get on in here where
I'm just talking about the elevator
how do you guys feel about it I felt
good a good panel yeah I liked it it's
nice not talking to airhead celebrities
we had the fun parts though where it's
we're not in the dogfight right I mean
we're not in there come on talk about
the things people get along having a
host of the show and then being on shows
you just sort of go along each host has
their own idea of how a show should be
and then you come in well I don't want
to be I would get this all the time [ __ ]
Mike my client has to leave right after
the segment they have something to do
yeah well and then the show would be
over and I see me standing in the hall
well it looks better if you leave you're
a [ __ ] you know so to me whatever the
host wants whatever your vision is for
the show that's fine tell me about this
new is it on CNBC Oh fie on CNBC I do it
on YouTube right now right so it's gonna
be chase gurage and we just cars and
history of cars
I was watching things that I've seen it
and it's great and you really do get
into like the history yeah I mean
interesting for people who are not car
people that's really the secret there's
a recent one where you're test driving a
Corvette oh the new zo6
yeah and you get pulled over we didn't
get that one it's not the real deal you
talk your way out of the ticket there's
actually a bench warrant out for
supposed to do what they do in case of
fire if you're blocking the car that
says oh what to do it now okay goes this
elevator hey you just started a new
season second season of midnight
yes the Richardson would start a couple
months ago
now we're you're at 11:30 ruin 11:00
it's confusing right 11:30 for another
week I mean until Larry Wilmore takes
over for Stephen Colbert so Colbert left
will Moore's coming in with the nightly
show and we're filling in for you know
for the first two weeks of our this
season that's great so you guys you have
a lot of exciting guests so far all
right yeah yeah yeah it's been it's been
really me so rules on the other name and
and and a lot of really great great
great great great comments what's going
on in the nerd world right now what are
people upset about I feel like there was
a nerd uprising when like Pluto got
kicked out of the planet system and then
another one when like gif became jiff
which I got some tweets about that
tonight people are mad at you and I said
yeah cuz I'm an orgy you know with a
hard G I like hard G some people say
jiff I say it's not a [ __ ] peanut
butter